now it is time for a pick from the
little yellow book my personal guide to
things i think would make your life
better
okay and today
it's an absolutely essential digital
helper that we might all need the
washington post's brand new help desk
they have gathered the crack team of
tech reporters to answer all of your
questions about how to get not only the
most out of your technology
but security
they show you how to do everything step
by step and here's their post on how to
improve your privacy something this is
very important to me please look at this
go to settings and privacy on the
website or on the app settings
ads ad settings and you're going to
click on data about your activity from
partners you're going to turn this off
for facebook and instagram
i mean that's just one of so many
elements they'll tell you how to close
windows say you don't agree ask you not
to track apps across this is really
pertinent information so that we can
live the most private life possible
while living in george orwell's 1984.
so uh ross did you have a tech question
yeah uh-huh so it's been a month and i
can't log into facebook so help
what's a two-step authentication code
tweet me don't not on facebook cause i
can't get into it tweet me at hello ross
and let me know i don't i can't figure
it out so my grandma she's posting
pictures i'm not seeing him grandma
this help desk from the washington post
and you know they're going to get it as
right as they can
i think is a great tip for the little
yellow book yeah we all need it yes we
do
well i just want to thank everybody for
joining us today here in the studio for
choosing your time to spend it with us
and to those at home and on the go the
most important thing about this whole
hour is we just want you to take it with
you and have a fantastic day everyone
[Music]
you